april dieses jahres den süddeutschen
wir haben uns heute hier was ja ein paar
stoppeln sieht dann glaube ich nicht die
stehen die steife wir kommen gerade aus
dem fitnessstudio meine damen und herren
ja wir machen sport ab und zu gehe ich
hab noch nicht geduscht ganz einfach aus
dem grund weil wir hier einige make-up
artikel vorbereitet haben und ich meine
ich brauche gar nicht mehr ran drumrum
lover sensation und sittel eingeblendet
meine freundin schminkt mich das schon
knallte losgehen hast du dir diese szene
haben aufsetzt und mit deine haare nicht
in deinem gesicht hängen
das wird super will der kann ja
eigentlich relativ gute hat benutzt und
ist reiser tintenfisch in der ist
nämlich viel zu dunkel aber die müsste
er sich ja ich bin einfach eine geile
sau aber nicht mal einen kanal ich winke
ich jetzt einfach so wie ich mich auch
nur mit mir hat da keine ahnung wie man
das ja ist ja kein problem es geht ja
noch darum bist du mich schminkt und ich
hatte so viel zu lachen
du hast ja ein großes gewicht gefühlte
halbe miete und ich hab das extra sauber
gemacht
er ist immer für dich habe ich extra
sagen was du machst du weißt ja das ist
angenehm dass eine gesichtsmassage ein
paar sekunden später das wort
mehr lippe jetzt gerade fühlt sich an
als jetzt und sofort getroffen
ich habe mir noch gar nicht aufmachen
sein linkes auge ist voll mit alter es
geht wirklich nicht
ich stelle mich nicht einig was mal rein
was ist denn das sohn ist ja ein
bisschen was man auf jeden fall weiter
mein ganzes t shirt ist voll mit
schminken
ich einstellen
juli fast immer so dass ich keine ahnung
aber nicht sagen
ich halte dein gestank auf wenn er haut
ist so trocken dass wird vom fleck sorry
hätte vielleicht vorher denken müssen
ist die queen macht steht der ganze
schminken nur aus ich sehe nicht ich
sehe wirklich nicht auf dem linken auge
ich bin blickt hier da ich dachte so
danke zu drehen wir uns jetzt hier mit
einem wasser das ist ein concealer auch
du nervst einen anderen haushalt
vielleicht weil überwinden dem spiel
wiederholt nur die frische gebrauchs
tags also ich weiß auch nicht wie man ja
jetzt geht es weiterhin mit dem pushen
so schmeckt nicht doch nicht oder ich
war vor diesem video echt davon
überzeugt dass du das mal machen weil
viele von euch das mal die wasserlinie
viele von euch haben sich gewünscht dass
ich mal schminkt und auch jule
gewünschte stelle mich völlig mit dem
nutzen
bei dem video war ich auf dem video war
ich auf jeden fall richtig richtig
gehabt mehr oder weniger ich das mal so
sagen kann auf das endergebnis am exer
den screen auch ein bisschen umgedreht
das sähe wenn die aufnahme schief läuft
oder so aber das hätte ich jetzt sehe
wie ich wirklich aus erding ist dass ich
gerade meine augen nicht öffnen kann
alles voll ist mit schminke nächstes
jahr nicht für den tränen
wir nehmen er hatte ich noch kurz im
einsatz denn sagen wollte sagen dass es
zu beginn wirklich begeistert war von
dieser idee und mittlerweile das glaube
ich echt beschissen idee ich glaube als
sonst machen das mit seinem losen
wieso machst du ne sinnlose bruder ich
habe so ein verstehe nicht wie das
gehört deswegen macht es immer so aber
und wieder direkt ins auge
du willst wir hier oben bringt das macht
das ist eigentlich immer überein
warum bloß vorwände zurück in die augen
genau so schön macht die sache
das ist denke ich doch mal für den
vergleich stehen recht heftig bekommt
hier 60 globetrotter madonna klatsch
wenn die fresse jetzt so mancher fische
und wie man seine wangenknochen bein
rein und dann gucken wir wo deine wann
sie fertig ich kriege noch nicht
bestimmt oder so ich brauche eine minute
für meine haare
diese würden nun aber auch ok mit haare
föhnen bleiben aber mit geht nur wenn
wir nicht nur haarstyling betrachtet man
nur mit gehe will ich sagen zehn
sekunden und schminken halt gar nicht
abonniert allem einen kanal freunde hast
du bist du nicht hätte ich habe ja auch
schon mal dich geschminkt das habe ich
auch richtig gut gemacht ich mache deine
nase sind klein
du machst bei der nase kleine warum
merkt meine nase ist ja dass man sagt
man die größe des jahres gesagt war das
auch über die nase eines mannes erkennt
man größe seines johannes der pause
machen
der nächste schritt ist jetzt lass mich
raten alle anderen neben den anderen ob
das machen wir hier so ein bisschen und
um jetzt noch mal die höheren partie in
deinem gesicht warum lachst du irgendwo
einen grundton die ganze zeit hast du
das absichtlich falsch gemacht oder was
jetzt die höheren beteiligen sich franz
beheben warum lachst du hier schon
wieder noch was denn falsch mit meinem
gesicht nehmen wir jetzt ein highlight
wieso hast du irgendwas absichtlich
falsch machen ich würde meinen augen
nicht aufmachen okay okay dann hörte ich
bin ernst nehmen denn da gerade ich
nehme das und lidschatten als highlight
highlight das tut genau und dann nehme
ich so einen kleinen pinsel
[Musik]
da hast du das ist mir jetzt nicht so
dass wir einen ganzen ins gesicht boxt
mit ihnen im schwarm top das wasserrad
mit zwei pinsel was mache ich seine
augenbrauen hat das hört sich so
ungefähr
manchmal der augenbrauen ich habe keine
ahnung ganze meinen augen wohnstift mit
einem augenbrauenstift also dem edding
oder den richtigen augenbrauen stadt ist
der ist super wenn sich der kurs 2015
also dass er sogar den teurer ist 40 gut
machen nun mal die andere seite nämlich
gute augenbrauen danke nein irgendwo
irgendwie voll ungleich was machst du
schon wieder hat die augenbrauen sind
vielleicht nichts ist ein meisterwerk im
gesicht habe ich halt so oft wie du mir
sagst du hast keine freunde habe ich
hier ist eine marotte smokie palette
gibt jetzt so gibt es ja auch für
nichtraucher verschiedene farben wird
diesen kursen schwamm star weil der
günstiges nie weil er damit bei ist also
umsonst so eine helvetische farbe darf
ich nur ganz kurz fragen wie lange wir
noch brauchen 2000 jahre da macht dafür
oben auf den augenblick als basis wird
man meinen bart nummer fühlen
mach mal toll der wie viele stoppeln
spielst du dabei
es ist nämlich diese farbe die so ein
bisschen daran hat auch clips auf dem
einen auge tut echt weh das ding da ist
wirklich irgend was drin
ich bin ich kann es nicht erwarten
gleich mit in den spiegel zu gucken dann
um das ganze abzurunden auf dem auge
nehmen wir noch mal wieder den
highlighter den ich eben schon benutzt
wird machen wir es hier auf die mitte
zum abschluss darfst du dir dann hier
ein
klaus spitzley fähig sei
ich würde mal sagen du bist du nimmst
jetzt mal die kamera ich drehe man den
bildschirm ohnehin zu gucken was wird
jetzt vor den spiegel und du film es
okay wenn ihr leben freuen und julia hat
mich geschminkt ich finde so ekelhaft
gerade so das gefühl ich merke dass ich
schminke im gesicht hat außer wirklich
auf den lippen es fühlt sich so an als
hätte ich da irgendwie so eine richtig
dicke creme drauf die richtig unangenehm
ist auf jeden fall gehe nicht nur zum
ersten mal zu einem spiegel in letzter
zeit eher nicht in den bildschirm
geguckt sondern meine augen zu gehabt
direkt neben mir ist ein spiegel bei der
lieben freunde ihr seht nicht
wahrscheinlich schon im spiegel
eingeblendet ist wäre das eingeblendete
wem ich halte ein spiegel sehr wohl was
erzählen augenbrauen hast du halt
hardcore fakt die sehen ja viel zu dick
aus und findet so eckig hier oben also
sich zu komisch aus aber sonst es ist
dich so schlecht geworden
also so wie es sich angefühlt hat was
ihr am ende hat man plötzlich 50 40
doppeln schon 35
[Musik]